We have one more thing to
learn about while loops, and
that's the break statement.
Break gives us a way to stop the loop,
even while the test condition is true.
So here's the typical structure
of a loop with a break.
So we have the while as we did before
and we have the : and
our general while structure
is we have a block.
Now we're going to look inside this
block a little bit to see the kinds of
things that could be here.
And this is just an example of
what might be in the block.
We have some code,
we have some python statements.
Then we have an if statement.
And that's going to have
another test expression.
We'll call that the break test.
That's a test expression that's checking
whether it's time to take a break.
When the break test is true,
What we have is break,
which by itself, is all we need.
What break means is stop executing
the while loop, jump out of the while loop and
continue with the code after that.
So whatever we had here, this is more
code that was in the while block.
That will get skipped and
we'll jump to this point,
which is the code after the while.
So what happens when we
execute a loop with a break,
it executes like a normal loop.
If the test expression is true, we go to
the code, if the break test is false,
we don't execute the break,
we would continue with the More Code.
We would go back to the loop test.
Check the test expression again,
if it is true, we go run this code.
If the break test is true,
then we execute the break and
what break does is jump out of the loop.
So we don't execute the more code we
don't execute the test expression again.
If the break happens, what happens is
we jump to the code after the while.
This gives us a way to break
out of the middle of the loop.
Here's an example of
how we might use that.
So before we define the procedure
print numbers without using break,
we defined it like this.
So this is the code we had before.
We could re-write that using break.
So now instead of having
the while test stop the loop,
we'll make the while test true.
True will never become false.
That means if we didn't have a break,
the loop would keep going forever.
But we're going to add a break.
We're going to have
an if test that says.
Well, the stopping condition
now is we're going to stop
once i is greater than n.
And the way to stop is to use break.
If i is not greater than n then
we're going to keep going.
We'll do the same thing we did before.
We'll print i.
And we'll add one to i.
So this look has exactly the same
meaning as the one we had before.
The previous one is better in every way,
right, so
this is more complex is more code.
This illustrates how we can use break.
We wouldn't want to do it this way.
This is much worse than
what we had before.
We want to keep our code simple and
easy to understand.
We'll see, once we get to the code for
abstracting all the links on the page,
that there are cases where it's
easier to write the code using break,
than it is without that.